So, WTF, OBS ist abgekackt. Übrigens, wir gewinnen das fast ohne Mischung gerade.
Weee, da fliegt er.
Ah, ich habe extra geholtet.
Extra geholtet für das scheiß Tire.
Aber viel zu früh vom Timing her.
Aber kannst ja mal probieren.
Go, go, Leute, drauf.
Der Dumpf ist ziemlich gut.
Perfekt.
Auf jetzt, drauf.
Zwei tot.
Go, go.
Ah, Mann.
Fuck.
Ich habe einen Schamkörner.
Was man am Rank ändern sollte.
Oh, da gibt es so viele Sachen.
Erstmal das ganze...
Sekunde kurz.
Erstmal das ganze Skill-Base-Zeug schwenken.
Weil du kannst in Overwatch nicht anhand von Stats gescheit entscheiden, wer jetzt dazu beigetragen hat, die Runde zu gewinnen oder nicht.
Das ist offensichtlich, wenn man sich...
Gucken wir uns mal Mercy an, ja?
Umso mehr, umso mehr.
Je mehr das Team rapet, umso schlechteres Stats hat Mercy.
In der Regel.
Umso weniger Razzis, umso weniger Heal, vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Damage-Boost.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Oh, Max, kannst du denn immer mal springen mit Lucy, oder was?
Ey, wir haben es gekriegt, sehr schön.
Haha.
What the fuck?
Wie viel muss ich machen?
Rage hat das Kackding.
Also bei der Rage hätte es nicht noch Auto-Aim sein müssen.
Fall runter.
Direkt.
So muss es sein.
Ja, es gibt Zeit.
Ich glaube, ich mache mal irgendwann ein Video dazu.
Ich reiße es dir immer mal wieder an, was mir an dem Rage-System nicht gefällt.
Aber ich bin auch nicht der Einzige.
Wirst du mehr Overwatch in nächster Zeit zocken?
Ja, bis 2025 jetzt.
Das erste Mal und dann Ranked.
So, und dann gucke ich mal, ob es mich so abfuckt wieder, da ich keinen Bock mehr drauf habe.
Ich meine, es gibt ja einige Streamer, die schaffen das, jeden Tag fünf Stunden Overwatch-Rank zu spielen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das schafft.
Aber man schafft es.
Warum habe ich keine 300?
Ich habe keine 300 FPS mehr.
Unspielbar.
Hehehe.
Rekt.
Lose your main, by the way.
Oh, der Fuck-Doomfist gefistet in den Arsch, ey.
Nicht gedoomfistet wurde ich gerade.
Anal gedoomfistet.
Hinterher, warte, fertig.
Nee, Tracer, so nicht.
Forget.
Fiss dich.
Ach, wir haben nur noch mich als Heiler.
Wunder.
Lasst euch doch heilen.
Bleibt doch einfach da.
So, das muss jetzt zum Abschluss mal sein.
Heute null Toxic gewesen, den ganzen Tag.
Dann mal jetzt.
Was haben die da eigentlich im Chat für Probleme gerade?
Ich bin der Erkst, Reddit-Post, Bann, Lootbox.
Übrigens, letzte Woche arbeiten für das Jahr.
Ich habe ganzen Dezember...
Dann Urlaub.
Und letzte Woche ist quasi vier Tage.
Dienstag, Mittwoch, Donnerstag, Freitag.
Freitag wahrscheinlich, wenn immer so viel sein wird.
GG.
Dann gibt es dann Stream, Video, alles.
Alles gibt es im Dezember dann.
Oh, ein paar epileptische Anfälle vom Schlafen gehen.
Was suchtest du dann die ganze Zeit?
Ich mache Videos.
Das kostet schon genug Zeit.
Du hast mich nicht wütend gesehen.
Doppel, Doppel, du hast es verpasst.
Na gut.
Ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen, Leute.
Nicht sterben, Bots.
Ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen.
Wir sehen uns beim nächsten Stream wieder.
Danke für die ganzen Follows und für die Donation.
Macht's gut.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.